so it looks like they'll cut back to the
house floor
so we'll we'll keep an eye on that but
uh
this bill was built with not just a
house in mind not just progressives in
mind not just with the white house in
mind but it was also built with cinnamon
mansion in mind and this is what i've
been saying is whatever bill comes to
the floor
uh from the house whatever comes out of
this uh
build back better act because what what
is going to happen today to reiterate if
you're just joining us is the speaker
has just uh said that they're going to
vote on infrastructure the physical
infrastructure package that is why
republicans are completely [ __ ]
terrified because that is a huge win
not just for the democrats not just for
the president but that is a huge win for
the citizens of the united states
as you heard whip clyburn if you were
joining us there and with the press
conference whip clyburn was saying look
the just the internet alone just the
internet alone in that [ __ ]
infrastructure bill is one of the best
things that could happen to america in a
long time as far as infrastructure is
concerned
just the internet part of it alone just
that if you just lay that part out of
the bill that is about to come to the
floor here soon and go to the
president's desk probably later this
evening we'll get a shot of the
president of the united states uh joe
biden let's go brandon he brandon's
gonna
brandon's gonna sign that [ __ ] bill
thank you brandon
thank you brandon
so we're gonna get uh
we're gonna get an infrastructure bill
tonight and the infrastructure bill
is gonna be signed by president joe
brandon i mean joe biden
and
and it really is gonna make trump look
like an impotent piece of [ __ ] because
he he he had infrastructure week for
four years straight four years straight
he had infrastructure week and couldn't
get an infrastructure package even into
a committee uh and here we are finally
at the end of the road for the physical
infrastructure package where it seems
like
sometime in the next few hours
we will see
a house floor vote for the physical
infrastructure bill it seems like they
whipped the votes and did a deal where
the progressives will let this bill go
to the floor and be voted on to to move
to the president's desk um if they will
move the rules vote to the floor for the
bill back better
act what that means is because there's
several votes that happen you don't just
bring a bill to the floor and vote you
got to bring the bill to the floor and
debate so the public can see it right
it's a public debate
and
what happens is they bring the phil bill
to the floor to agree on the rules of
the debate
of the bill
right so in other words how you can make
amendments how we can take parts out put
parts in you know and all that will
happen on the floor
after they come back from their break
because what the democrats and the
progressives and and even the moderates
have agreed to here is to get the rules
vote done today
that way the rules are agreed upon for
that bill to work its way to the floor
once they come back from their break so
they can hash out that bill there's a
couple different things in play here
number one progressives want to have a
little more time probably to make sure
these pieces that they want inside the
reconciliation package are there and and
also work out whatever negotiations they
need for cinnamon mansion to vote for
this thing which i think they're going
to vote for it no matter what it is no
matter what it is cinema mansion are
going to vote for this on there's no way
they've did they've done this whole
[ __ ] charade this whole time
and they're not going to vote on this
thing it's going gonna get voted on
there's no way nancy pelosi would bring
this bill forward and do this deal if it
wasn't now i think the other thing here
too is moderates in the house caucus for
the democrats is is uh wanting to get
this cbo score well um
bringing the rules committee and pushing
the bill forward after the break gives
the cbo time to score this bill so that
way
you know again this is all about the
stupid money that's that's why we're
still
that's why we're still [ __ ] around
with this is because they've
concentrated on the money too long you
get in this trap with [ __ ]
republicans in this country about oh
paying taxes and not paying taxes and
who's paying for it and what's free and
what's not you know that's a dumb
[ __ ] debate for us to have it really
is a stupid [ __ ] debate for us to
have moderates
it really is a stupid debate
for moderates to have
moderates
to to [ __ ] debate taxes and not taxes
and how it's free and how it's not free
because that's all [ __ ] that's all
[ __ ] you want to pay for this bill
you can pay for this bill there's a lot
of different ways to pay for this bill
they've had several different ways to
pay for it the easiest way is what most
people in this country think should
happen which is the rich should pay
their fair share and we should tax the
rich to pay for it
that's pretty simple well guess what if
we want to do that we're going to have
to vote for democrats in 2022 whether
you're moderate whether you're an
anti-trumper
whether you're an independent or whether
you're a democrat or you're a
conservative democrat or you're a
liberal or you're a democratic socialist
we have to have this bill pass so that
way in 2022 we can vote in democrats no
matter who they are in your district no
matter who they are we have to vote them
in for senate and for the house so that
way so that way
we can make sure to pass um the taxing
creatures on the rich to pay for this at
the cbo or if something happens and we
need to pay for it we can pay for it
it's pretty simple just raise taxes on
the rich after 2022 when the democratic
party holds the house holds the senate
and we can get rid of the filibuster
because we'll make cinema and mansion
irrelevant
to have if we have 54
53 54 votes
in the senate so
this is all important i i i think um
nancy pelosi coming out and signaling
this is what's gonna happen here
um there's they're still waiting there
it looks like they're still
whipping the count a little bit here
with the democrats if you see on the
screen here there's still 32 no votes
for the democrats
um
they're still whipping count meaning
meaning they're still trying to figure
out who's gonna vote
um for and against and that sort of
thing because some of them want the room
to say well i didn't i didn't want this
or i didn't want that or some [ __ ]
they think it's good for their race for
re-election
in other words
in other words they want to stay in
power and i think it's good to
to play with this nonsense which i think
that's a
mistake
why don't we go back to the
let's go back to the
the white house uh briefing here
and see if we can
uh hear a little more about what the
president and the white